the us
intelligence council or the nic has
punched a ton of data into their spy
machines and set out five different
scenarios of what the world would look
like in 2040
and boy they sure are scared of china
every four years the nic releases a
global trends document
that predicts hold on a second they
don't like to use that word
they say it like this global trends is
designed to provide an analytic
framework for policymakers early in each
administration as they craft national
security strategy and navigate an
uncertain future
the goal is not to offer a specific
prediction of the world in 2040. so this
analytic framework talks about stuff
like diseases the gap between the rich
and poor
climate change conflicts all that
malarkey and comes up with five
predictions
sorry scenarios of what your future is
going to look like
in the year 2040. so come on let's dip
our toes in the future
a us vision future that is global trends
2040. it's quite a long story short i'm
paraphrasing these and sticking them in
layman's terms
scenario one renaissance of democracies
america is the leader of open
democracies and steals the best
scientists and entrepreneurs
from naughty china and russia and
america is great
scenario two a world adrift the whole
planet is in complete chaos because
china won't listen to america
but china lacks the military might to
completely take over the world because
america is great scenario three
competitive coexistence
china is being led by america and the
world is absolutely
buzzing technology is thriving because
china have let america in on their
secrets but
climate change is a problem and america
is great
scenario for separate silos nations will
vary in size and strength
nobody cares about climate change and a
massive war is brewing
and america is growing scenario 5
tragedy and mobilization
so in this final 2040 scenario
the eu have teamed up with china and
climate change is being addressed
it's the most optimistic of scenarios
and there's no specific mention of
america
so that's it the us has told your future
don't take my word for it go and
download the 156 page document from
their website
and your good old-fashioned us ipad made
in china